I think women kill it in fact my
Construction Company
all of my managers outside the managers
that are in the field are women and
they're very good at they're very
organized I call them my Trojan horses
because they get more in a negotiation
than a man could because it's not a dick
measuring thing right but at the same
time a lot of those women are past the
years of being a mother and their kids
are grown and they're in their 50s and
their professional business women but I
suspect that any woman that it's a high
level guy who chooses her and chooses to
trust her with one of the most important
things in this world his children that
should be an honor past any other job
that I can think of for a woman now does
that mean that a woman can't go out
there and make money and have an impact
on the world outside to be a mother no
it doesn't women can just buy in largely
on the macro what a beautiful job to
have